Hello, everybody. This is Dr. Kevin Cutters. We're going to talk about pain control with people with cancer.
This is actually for anybody with pain control, but mainly dealing with our cancer patients here.
And it's certainly not going to be exhaustive.
It's maybe just a brief overview to touch on some natural things that can be done.
And what are some standards of care that is done.
Typically, if you have a diagnosis of cancer, you're in a lot of pain.
They're going to give you medications.
So initially, they're starting off depending on one level of pain that you start off with.
With some over the couture, cox to inhibitors, nuts, toilet and inflammatory drugs.
So over the couture medications like Tylenol and Advil to help reduce pain.
If you remember, if you've watched any of the genetic videos, and if you have a defect on that specific ABP1 gene that helps you detox, non-steroidal anti-inflammatory drugs,
then you really can't be using insads on a very regular basis because it's going to cause liver damage, or you have the potential of causing liver damage
and having liver toxicity due to the insads.
So can't detoxify them. It's going to really damage your liver.
So you're limited, unfortunately.
So the paid medication that you're going to get in the form of a drug medication is going to be more powerful, obviously, than a natural approach.
So if a person is in very severe pain, some of the natural approaches that we're going to talk about are just not going to touch it.
And then we're really kind of destined to use some of the standards of care with drug therapy to help reduce the pain.
We certainly don't want to jump on the bandwagon right away and jump on opioids or something like that to reduce pain without trying some natural things
because the side effects of these are great from dependence to severe constipation to alteration and brain function and actually an op-regulation of certain receptor sites, different neurons that can be permanent.
So we don't want to go the standard of care route with medication right off the bat.
So if you've come to the clinic and you're already on opioids and try to get off, some of the things that we're going to talk about in this lecture will help you if you're prior to taking these, this lecture might be more advantageous for you.
So some natural things that you can do in conjunction with any of these natural things can be taken in conjunction with any medications that you're taking and will help reduce the dose possibility of reducing the dose of the medication if you couple it with some natural things.
And we've had patients get off of their pain meds by using some natural things.
The anti-inflammatories like white willow bark, ginger, curcumin, boswellia, capsacin can be extremely beneficial because most of the pain that you're dealing with with cancer is inflammatory pain and these can be very beneficial.
Even metastasis that the bone is going to be an inflammatory type pain. So decreasing the inflammation could be a real key.
The use of CBD oil and THC to different components of the marijuana plant have improvement just phenomenal for pain.
Many people respond to the straight CBD oil very well and it really helps decrease the pain.
Smoky marijuana or using marijuana as an edible in the states that allow you to do that legally can be extremely beneficial and should be really maybe one of the first choices for severe pain relief.
But certainly using three to six grams of curcumin. We use the curcuclear, which is the tetrahydro curcuminoid.
That's our brand. We have the anti-inflammatory mixed clear inflame that has ginger, white willow bark, curcumin, boswellia, and capsacin in it.
We also use straight capsacin. Use the CBD oil since we can legally sell that in the THC or you have to get that independently in the states that make that legal.
The other thing we want to look at when we look at natural alternatives to try to reduce pain is understand the pain pathway.
Pain pathways come from receptors in the extremity. So if you step out a nail or you get hit by a tack in your in your hand, that pain pathway fires back the specific a fair and pathways, the small diameter, effort and pathway is your main pathway that it fires back on.
This is the spinal cord right here. It desiccates or crosses over the spinal cord goes up to the braid to the opposite side of the parietal lobe of your braid and that's where you actually feel the pain.
So if my right hand got stuck with a pack, it would be fire-eated by left parietal lobe, my primary sensory portion of my left parietal lobe that has a bathtub by right hand telling me that I am paid.
So we could inhibit the pain by looking at understanding that pathway. Let me explain.
So that pathway that carries pain is called the small diameter, effort, pathway and there's another pathway called the large diameter, effort, effort means just from the extremities up to the braid, that large diameter, effort, which is just a larger pathway.
It inhibits the small diameter, pain pathway. So the large diameter pathway carries light touch, vibration, hot cold sensation from receptors in the extremities and that inhibits the small diameter, effort, pathway or the pain pathway.
So summarize that again. Light touch, vibration and hot and cold stimulation to the extremities inhibits pain.
So if I use a heating pad on my back, I feel better. If I use ice on my back, I feel better.
If I use a vibration platform, it can inhibit pain. If I get out and walk and just get some activity, this is where you hear a lot of people will say, I have pain grade four or five, but if I keep myself busy, get out in the workshop, go to work, get outside with the grandkids, I don't feel like pain.
I think I'm just taking my mind off of it. Well, there's a portion of it that you are just taking your mind off the pain. So not thinking about it can help inhibit pain by itself, but the art of activity, the actual activity itself stimulates the large diameter, effort, pathway, which will then inhibit the pain pathway.
Do it across crawl exercise, which is technically a walk eater or an exaggerated walk will help inhibit pain acupuncture inhibits paid on this and other pathways.
Things like dry brush sheet and massage can help inhibit pain. So hot and cold pack, I don't have a type down here, heating pad ice vibration activity cross crawl acupuncture massage therapy.
Stimulation of the skin just touching just hugging can help inhibit pain. So all those are neurological inhibition pathways. Also, you could use some tools, like a tens unit works great to inhibit pain. Here's the tens unit that we sell in our office about $35 pretty cheap just runs off of battery.
You literally take these stickers connected to these wires, the wires connect right here, and you could use just two pads or you could use four pads to connect into this lead to connect to this lead both separate controls and you stick the pads on the area of pain on the tens unit doesn't seem to doesn't tend to work real well if I have
a large area of diffuse pain let's say my whole belly hurts and I just get paid all over very diffuse in my whole intestinal tract while you have to be a little bit more knowledgeable and where you're placing the tens unit then because then I would before you to place the tens unit at the spine and a higher level.
Or a lower level than the pain so you can actually put it at the spine down at the lumbar spine and it could help inhibit the pain neurologically that way.
But typically you use the tens unit for more specific areas of pain let's say I have metastasis to my hip bone I would put these pads right over the area that you physically feel the pain.
And then you turn it up to a level that you're comfortable with and the tens unit is stimulating in capillan and endorphin release of the muscles and those are that's natural opioids basically your natural pain relief system so by doing that you're helping block those pain pathways naturally.
The tens unit was created for people with chronic pain to actually use 24 seven if they would you stick this little thing in your pocket or I think ours has a clip on it for your belt clip or a pad clip and you can turn it up to a level where it feels like it's starting to cut the pain and you can leave it on for anywhere from 15 to 30 minutes to hours to days at a time.
And these are typically sticky pads you want to put them back on this this piece of plastic when you're done always do it with skill that's dry doesn't have any lotion on it because the these pads themselves can cost you more money than the unit the longer you use this so you want to try to keep those safe.
The P E M F the pulse to electromagnetic field therapy which we use in our office some of you have that as a whole unit as well or a clinic near you that uses it the P E M F is a wonderful paid reducing therapy.
That effect most clinics that have a P E M F unit are using it for pain reduction or for peripheral neuropathy or something like that injured knees injured hips so the P E M F is a wonderful tool to help cut pain you could do that right over your abdomen if you have abdominal pain.
Over the pancreas over the liver you can do it over organs it's much more effective than the tens unit for diffuse pain and it's a great tool to help cut pain and help increase healing and help increase your phase angle and sell charge etc it's a great tool class for laser is another great tool for paid that can might be a miracle eraser for pain.
So we are big into using class for laser here probably use it much less than we should use it a vibration plate that we discussed back here because vibration is stimulating the large diameter effort pathway that will then inhibit your pain pathway.
But a vi plate can be purchased on Amazon typically so like as a foot massager you just put your feet on this vi plate if you have anybody at home has a back massager vibration tool you can flip it over and put on the floor and put your feet on it and stimulate your feet.
While I'm a pain of my feet yeah but you're stimulating the large diameter effort pathway as far away from the brain as you can get which your feet would be a perfect spot for it and you could run that that will that will help inhibit pain all the way up to the cord so that can be very beneficial.
So just different ways to deal with pain obviously if your pain is in the 7-8-9-10 range you're most likely going to have to resort to some medication use this is where possibly marijuana use would be most advantageous as far as trying to cut down on the opioid use.
But are at pain many times will be controlled solely by using pf using 10th using curcumid musuelia marijuana can come in there as well using anti-inflammatory oral anti-inflammatories usually works just fine for lighter pain obviously we want to try to reduce the amount of medication that we're taking.
But we also don't want to get anybody in a situation where the pain gets out of control and it's more difficult to manage so please consult your physician before you try to reduce or eliminate any medication we can't help you with that legally because you need to consult the physician who gave you the script for that medication.
But in trying to do so most physicians are going to be more than able to try to help you reduce the amount of medication that you're taking especially pain medication since it's such an iffy subject right now.
So things to work on give you some tools to work on I hope this helps thanks so much.